this this over emphasis on juneteenth
though
it doesn't actually tell the full story
which is nine out of 13
colonies that signed the deck of the
colonies that
signed on to the constitution in 1787
had already independently abolished
slavery by the time we had a
constitution
vermont abolished slavery in 1777
because of the declaration
the first ever anti-slavery convention
that happened in the world
was chaired by benjamin franklin in
philadelphia in 1775
and so this idea that we were nothing
but slavery apologists
that that no i know you're not saying 60
19 is trash no no but the juneteenth
holiday is is being masterminded by
nicole hannah jones and robin deandra
let me just give you an example that
kind of affirmed my my rejection of the
juneteenth holiday was evanston illinois
so evanston illinois they had a lbgt
pride parade
a juneteenth parade and canceled their
july fourth parade yup yup
and then they canceled july 4th for
covet or something right yeah that's a
bunch of garbage so this mayor who i go
back and forth i grew up right down the
street from you know
i know the type right he is the worst
type of like upper middle class
double mask wearing while i shower
liberal right like get vaccinated five
times or else you're the worst person
ever
and so i said okay mr mayor then why
don't you demand that there's a july 4th
parade
are you just like all of a sudden be
like oh i'm not going to take a stance
on this he issues this long statement
because for him there's no moral
difference
between an lgbt pride parade and the
july 4th
and for me personally july 4th far
transcends an lgbt pride parade it's
it's a it's a it's the direct line of
why we exist as a nation
and so anyway if it was it was an
ideological revolution
as well as a political one totally it
was a bunch of people saying
divine providence is does not a a uh
executive make
you do not get be the head of state
simply because religion wills it or god
will
totally and i don't mean to monopolize
this but as we're here this weekend on
the declaration
what's so amazing when thomas jefferson
wrote the declaration it was kind of a
committee and benjamin franklin chaired
the committee
first of all the original draft of the
declaration of independence in thomas
jefferson's own handwriting
he blames king george for bringing the
sin of slavery to america
thomas jefferson in the original draft
in his own handwriting
now it didn't make the final draft
because they needed slave holding states
to obviously build a coalition to be
able to fight a successful war
against britain the declaration starts
super wide
when in the course of human events so
what does that mean you run human
events.com will
he's making an argument that this
document right here
is about human beings right to govern
themselves that's a big
claim that's not just some sort of like
we think we can do something better it's
like you know what
the way we've been doing government is
wrong then it gets very narrow king
george did this king georgia this king
george this then it gets really really
wide the widest you can be
we appeal to the supreme the supreme
power which is of course our creator
and it says earlier laws of nature and
nature's god and it ends with we pledge
our lives our fortunes and our sacred
honor what does that mean
those 56 signers of the declaration they
were pledging it to each other
now out of the 56 signers we know at
least eight of them were hunted down and
killed in the
months right after the declaration about
12 of them i'm getting my numbers wrong
twelve of them were died in the war and
another six had their entire fortunes
gone i don't know if that there's a meme
going around saying those things i think
they may be a bit exaggerated
so i did a lot of fact checking on this
and it's like
semantically true like i think a lot of
people were really gung-ho and said they
were hunted down and killed and it was
like
they started a war they got killed in
they weren't hunted down
like you could be right i mean they
signed it in philadelphia in the middle
of a summer
in the summer which it was a port city
against a naval power
so they knew that there was going to be
some race well it was the greatest
military power the world had ever seen
totally they knew they were going to
lose actually this is
something americans need to realize the
americans were like we're going to lose
this war you know and they're like
eff it i refuse to bend the knee
wow and then the french were like we
don't like the british either so we're
going to lend support to screw with them
and if it was not for the french
intervention america probably would not
have won
yeah and i mean edmund burke who's kind
of like the father of western
conservatism
uh him and pitt they tried to tell
britain not to wage this war
because they said look we have more
military might but they have something
we don't have
they have resilience and they're going
to run to the hills and they're going to
run to the rivers and they're going to
outlast us
it was kind of the first ever guerrilla
war right it was kind of
why the viet cong were able to outlast
us it's why the taliban was able to
outlast us
we were kind of the taliban viet cong
equivalent you can't
in my opinion uh for the most part win a
war without
propaganda and economics those are those
are huge components of a war
if you simply go in and start gun guns a
blazin
the people will be resilient in their
opposition to you you will need
massive massive military might and that
means
boots on the ground to occupy street
corners the problem with the british was
that
they're thousands of miles away and when
they come
and they occupy these homes and they
ransack it would make people angry and
actually rally the cause
in many ways of the of the revolution
the difficult thing was
how do you control the hearts and minds
of the people so going back to the point
about the signers and what they
sacrificed
there are there there are very serious
ramifications there's a meme that goes
around where it lists everything that
happened
i went through the list and i and i did
some fact checking
there was i think one guy who who
directly fought in the war and died
there was a a a dozen or so who had
their homes occupied or ransacked
it wasn't you know uh these are these
were these were men
who when they when they uh said they
were putting their honor their treasure
their lives
it wasn't just that it was their
families one guy had his wife kidnapped
by the british
to be used as a is in a prisoner
exchange so
when they capture an officer or
something they're like i got your wife
that that that was a serious pledge to
make looking at your wife and being like
they might kill you i think ben
franklin's son joined the british never
talked to his dad again oh wow
really yeah i'm gonna look that up
really quick yeah one one cool thing is
i think george washington said he would
never set foot on british soil ever
again
so now that you know we're kind of cool
with the uk they shipped in a bunch of
u.s soil
in the uk and put it down and then built
a statue of george washington on it
yeah it's a story i don't know how true
it is but you know well i just think
going back to the earlier part you said
the canadians just took down a queen
elizabeth stature i'm like who do you
think canada where do you think your
ancestors were
they were the loyalists right yep yep
but that's why
that's why when i saw that happen i was
kind of like you know hey look my i was
reading about this my understanding is
that
we did petition quebec to join the
revolution
and they said well so in the declaration
of independence
there's a there's a sentence that king
george made us subjected to foreign
powers
they were talking quebec thomas
jefferson was was complaining about the
canadians
actually just learned indians i just i
just learned that the other day and you
know we almost got
canada or something it wasn't that war
of 1812 i think what because the lake
champlain borders right up against lake
erie
and so the turning point of the war of
1812 was
the anchored ship in lake champlain were
able to do a run around and change the
entire course of the war but yes
um i mean the french were selling land
like it was going out of style
and thomas jefferson took full advantage
of that yeah the louisiana purchase
no no but there was uh montreal i can't
remember exactly what happened but we we
sent our forces up to like montreal and
then they went ransacked the white house
or whatever yeah we kind of
i don't know i don't know if maybe my
opinion is you know wrong in this
charlie my understanding is we kind of
got beat up in the war of 1812
we were getting rolled and then yeah
that's that's my read too and then all
of a sudden
napoleon's a problem and the british are
like okay like we got we got more
important issues so we'll make it a
generous more the little man is causing
us a lot of problems but there was two
miracles that happened in the war of
1812 is the miracle of lake champlain
and then the miracle of the storm that
put out all the fires in washington dc
when the british were burning the
warriors
yeah two divine points of intervention
and i don't mean this
sidebar but there was one that involved
benedict arnold two on the hudson river
but we can get to what was that no
it was so it's a really interesting
story um benedict arnold obviously was
selling
secrets to the british for money um and
he was in charge of west point which is
obviously now or the united states
military academy
and so the person that was in charge of
transmitting benedict arnold's orders
had him in his had it in his sports
jacket or
sports coat goes south on the hudson
river down to what is now the dutch
which was the dutch new york city and
dutch port of new york city
and an american colonialist cannon
shoots at this guy's
boat misses the boat but skims like a
piece of wood on the boat and
it goes up into the captain's nose
that's carrying the orders from benedict
arnold right
basically in writing that benedict
arnold sold out the american
revolutionary forces
and so he gets really annoyed by this
little piece of wood
and he's like you know what screw it i
can't be the captain of the ship go to
shore and we'll find a new captain like
basically
i need to kind of like go find go find
someone who can extract this
when they do that they get to shore and
some american minutemen intercept the
ship
and take them all prisoner when they
take him prisoner they find benedict
arnold's handwriting and concession
orders
that were selling out west point our
most pivotal military base to the
britain
so if it wasn't for this little piece of
wood which i would consider to be
basically divine intervention we never
would have found about benedict arnold
who sold out our troops and then they go
back to george washington
george washington has kind of an aha
moment he's like this is why the british
always know what i'm doing before i do
it and some would say that would be the
turning point what evolutionary award
so i think about july 4th and how i know
about these things
and i think about the civil rights
movement and how i know about these
things
like these are things that are deeply
important to to my family and i love
this line
they probably said the same of you but
they say they say to me and it makes me
laugh a whole lot
there was a i made a there's a there's a
um i should have pulled it up there's on
twitter this this this guy
posts a photo of the civil rights march
and he says stop this woke mob
and it's 1960s civil rights and the sign
right in front says end segregation
rules in schools
and i'm like hey about that so i went
and i got that famous
photo where they color they race
segregated uh people of color and
and non-people of color diversity
meetings
and i'm like this is exactly what i'm
complaining about and have been
complaining about
somebody responds with if tim poole was
a commenter in the in the 80s he would
have been pro apartheid
if tim poole was a commenter during
civil rights he would have been pro
whites only and i'm like i'm against
these things because i come from a mixed
race family you
morons it is like you talk about
identity
and you talk about racism and you talk
about how people have this perspective
based on their on their world views and
then when i straight up say it like yes
these these laws are bad
because of exactly what you're saying
they say not you you'd support all the
white people
i wouldn't be allowed to what are you
talking about my family went through
hell
in in those years these people don't
understand anything to do
with the historical struggle and how
america
planted the sea the founding fathers to
create a great nation where we were able
to win civil rights expand civil rights
quite honestly the greatest country on
the planet because of the freedoms that
we allow people upward mobility the
american dream you're not going to find
it anywhere else and let me just say one
more thing
identitarianism which is the core of
what the critical race theorists want
and the white nationalists is the rule
of law for the planet
90 something percent of it and it has
been the rule of law for humanity
for every single year of human existence
until
1964 we've had what 57 years of being
like okay we're not going to base laws
on race anymore and they're trying to
bring us back
those people yeah just to complete the
point
identitarianism was not present in the
philosophical community
were of the founders until a man by the
name of john c calhoun came along who
became
kind of the philosophical father of
american identitarianism
and john c calhoun was the vice
president for john quincy adams and
andrew jackson
and he made the argument that basically
rights must be earned
that they are not unalienable that that
that you must go through a series of
choices and decisions
and he said that blacks cannot earn them
and then his philosophical line goes
straight to
nathan bedford forest the founder of the
kkk and now the current ambassadors
nicole hannah jones
it's funny how the democrats are
historically just uh i i love how uh
amazingly it's such an easy meme for the
left where they're like
oh you're you're saying that the
democrats are the party of the clan well
the party's switched
and i'm like i don't know what that
means never happened what is that what
does that even mean it's they're the
party of like
tribal morality that's so true and and
so i i
one example i don't know if we've talked
about this recently but you probably
talked about it a few months ago do you
remember
that video of you know it was a police
shooting
where the policeman shot um the girl who
was about to stab
yes yes you remember that and it was at
a striker that was in north carolina i
was in north carolina right
and remember that like a huge number of
black lives matter activists some of the
were out there trying to say that that
wasn't a justified shoot
right as though it were and and i was
like this blew me in my mind i don't
know if it
you know it just was is amazing that
somebody could advocate that but i
really you know
i read a really good book uh the
weirdest people in the world and it
talked about
kind of how our morality is actually
historically very strange
right the idea of kind of a universal
morality as opposed to one that is like
as more uh localized where you right
you know tribalist tribalist you you
value your relationships like for
example you ask the question like
would you uh purge yourself to get your
brother off a charge and if you ask that
in the united states people like of
course not we wouldn't do that
but if you ask that like in other places
people are like of course i would
how would i be disloyal to my brother
it's a different right
right right and so like both you know
the white nationalists are trying to say
tribal morality
right focus on us you know over other
people
black lives matter saying like this you
know children fighting with knives is an
internal dispute and you an outsider
shouldn't even take part in it
right like yeah that's what this is it's
like a return to travel i actually i
agree with their message
i mean look i i think that story was an
absolute tragedy
this cop runs in trying to save lives
sees someone pull a knife
he does what he what he tries to stop a
violent assault
i mean that cop must have been i i'm
sure he he
he went through some very serious trauma
when he realized like she was the one
who called for his help and he comes in
and he doesn't know what's going on
there's a lot of instances where
sure you have cops who who do stupid or
bad things and there are a lot of
instances where there was one video
recently where a cop shoots a guy and
then immediately falls to the ground
this like 220 pound thick guy
clearly in his 40s starts bawling his
eyes out that he just shot somebody and
he's shaking like
he just killed a man he knows it these
they act like
these cops are machines but to the point
about the tribal morality
if there's a community of people saying
don't come police then i simply say
okay we have a right to self-governance
right if community says we don't want
cops in this neighborhood and we want to
solve our disputes with knives
the police should respect the community
right i mentioned that there was a story
to new york
that's that's libertarian stuff we're
conservative oh for sure for sure
let's argue for sure but let me make one
more point there was that story out of
new york where the woman ran up to the
other woman and put a bullet in her head
two black women where was the where were
the marches of black lives matter
where were the calls for justice where
were the vigils
they the the activists of black lives
matter and high profile individuals
didn't care
when there was an internal dispute in
the black community in new york that
resulted in death
and my response is they clearly don't
care about this
why should we impose our will on them
so right that's so let me just say a lot
of people
are starting to say this and the danger
is then
well was dwight d eisenhower wrong to
mobilize the national guard to
desegregate southern schools
it's tough question isn't it because i'm
not saying desegregating schools i'm
like yeah that was good i mean i
literally just said my family went
through civil rights
i know but how are you to tell the white
southerners that they can't govern
themselves i know
that's you you got me yeah we we we we
need to enforce our laws
right so so but i will stress the point
when i'm saying
don't send the police in i'm not
principally
and literally saying all right no i'm
i'm trying to make a point
that if these people i hear you yeah a
lot of people are saying like you hate
us
you hate us the police structure so much
then go take care of your own affairs
that is a tempting thing to believe
but the the extrapolation of that belief
ends up into hundreds and thousands of
city-states
where we no longer have a common tie to
our fellow countrymen therefore
the promise of the constitution of the
declaration gets invalidated
let me let me let me ask you a question
so desegregation of schools the national
guard comes in
and you are you are saying it was a good
thing that we
i think it was a moral thing to do for
dwight d eisenhower to mobilize
the national the national guard george
wallace back down if there
is a florist who refuses to provide
services to a gay wedding
should the courts get involved and force
the the floors to it's a great question
and it's a completely it's a completely
separate issue it's similar and it feels
similar and it's because
religious choice is directly protected
in the first amendment in two different
things the establishment clause and the
free expression clause
racial discrimination is not now so the
courts have articulated what a religious
test
is so some people say well my religion
allows me to be
racist the courts have not upheld that
ever
right so for example the court case that
continually comes up is this colorado
baker right who just is getting sued
again by the way
is that he has a business that requires
an application process
he has a deliberate action where he has
to make a good and he feels that
homosexual marriage is in direct
contradiction to his scriptural belief
does he have the right to say
i don't want to do this you have to go
to another baker and
we say of course i mean that that is a
very specifically go ahead just a real
quick point
he wasn't denying them service he was
denying to say a certain thing on the
cake
that's right it was it was it was it was
compulsory speech that's exactly right
that's why he
won i believe he won but he just lost
another appeal they've sued him six
times i've met him he's like the
sweetest guy
and so this is another important point
though is that when they can't win in
the courts
the process becomes the punishment right
so so they're not going to put this guy
in prison ever
instead they're going to put him through
a 20-year open year prison of millions
of dollars of legal fees names in his
names in the newspaper his business
basically you know on the verge of
bankruptcy
at that point the process becomes the
punishment but your question's a good
one right
which is well what's the difference
between racial discrimination and the
reintegration of schools
and the bakery number one the bakery is
a private establishment and it's not
technically bound
by the first amendment so that meaning
that that baker is allowed to have
some form of conscious and different of
opinion where a public school system has
to be somewhat
viewpoint neutral and accepting to every
single person that local area
with that being said the courts have
added a tremendous amount of nuance of
what a religious test actually is
for example there were some people that
were coming out there saying like
my my interpretation of christianity
says i don't have to serve black people
the courts knew that was not an argument
made in good faith and they dismissed
that kind of lawsuit that's why we have
prudence practical judgment right
whereas we can see with the baker in
colorado that this guy had a legitimate
religious tradition of a well-recognized
church
that was well attended you see what i'm
saying and and the specific issue was
he offered up to these men any cake
that's exactly right that they wanted so
he was making
faith he would not write a message yeah
so he was trying to provide the service
of course uh i'll tell you something
really funny there was this uh bill
uh ohio a religious freedom act i think
it was when i was working for fusion
fusion of course was the disney
univision company when i worked there uh
they said they wanted to be edgy and all
that stuff and they got woke
there's a story that came out where
every celebrity this is like a big red
pill moment
for me for sure uh the every celebrity
was coming out saying this bill was
anti-lgbtq and all this stuff
and so we were like oh wow what a story
and then we get we get like the
editorial meetings and they're like wow
this this
this story is you know crazy look what
they're doing they're suppressing the
rights of these people with this free
with religious freedom bill
and so uh they were like you know tim
would you want to produce a video on
this and i'm like yeah let's do it so i
get this other you know young millennial
lefty
and we're like all right let's start
doing the research and we start doing
the research and we're like
wait wait wait what like half the things
that these celebrities are claiming
isn't true
we got really confused so we go back to
some of the other journalists who are
asking questions like hey we have the
bill
and they they it just it didn't make
sense to us we were very confused what
the activists were claiming what the
bill actually did
was just functionally not true like it
was wrong
and so then i'm like i don't think we
can do the kind of video you want like
we'll do a video about it we'll talk
about it
but what you were saying about it is
wrong and not the case
like what is this yeah i mean
well you know with when i talk about you
know for example platform access being
civil right i often get pushback about
the forest right like they say well if
you think twitter has to let you speak
what do you think about the baker in
colorado and i think in addition to sort
of the the freedom of religion wrinkle
that you're talking about there's also a
scale issue
totally um right like there's you know
in general i think it's not wrong to
think we should impose
stricter and be willing to impose
stricter regulations on trillion-dollar
tech monopolies
than on individual bakers in colorado um
i think that there's no
and the idea that we have to have the
same level of civil rights law applied
to both
is wrong and i mean i can simultaneously
also think that you know the civil
rights act of 1964 was absolutely
righteous to break the regime of private
discrimination
in the in the jim crow south um that you
know
it's just completely unacceptable that a
black person driving from washington dc
to austin
could would have to drive 50 miles out
of the way to stay in a motel or go to a
restaurant absurd and something that we
didn't have to tolerate
and also think that it's extraordinarily
oppressive for this one single baker in
colorado to be the target of this
onslaught of just of litigation just
look at the organizational power they've
thrown at this man
that they don't throw at massive tech
monopolies
even when they censor the left right
like
there is institutional power among very
wealthy elites
to go after the little guy you know why
they understand the power of the
grassroots
they understand the power of snipping
the stem you want you
you're worried about a plant they just
cut it off at the root they go for the
little guy
they want to send a message if you
oppose us this is what you get now
we have that news the supreme court
won't take up the case of the florist
it's the most selective libertarianism
in the world the left is only
libertarian
for the big tech monopolies in every
other sense they are i i love
the the leftist person i was on youtube
saying but they're private companies
it's like bro can i go through your
10-year youtube history of all your
anti-corporate messaging
and please ask you to be consistent and
also this is just a great example
of when extra abstractions go wrong
let's just use a little bit of prudence
and practical wisdom
you have a combined market
capitalization value of six trillion
dollars of four companies
we're really gonna all of a sudden make
a scale and size argument to your point
will
that the the baker in colorado has the
same sort of
impact on humanity that four companies
with a six trillion dollar
market capitalization do that have
entire departments of
thousands of employees earning hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year
that do nothing but artificial
intelligence and these are information
highways and we have laws about
interstate highways
so the chicago skyway is a private
highway it goes from south bend indiana
to downtown chicago
on the chicago sky which owned by
private bondholders they are not allowed
to put a sign that says that
republicans are not allowed to drive on
this highway open access
anyone can drive on that highway it is
exactly the same with these big tech
companies these are information highways
and we have a moral right to be able to
speak on them i agree
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you